cholesterol okay I want to talk about
cholesterol statin drugs hundreds of
millions of prescriptions are filled for
statin drugs every year everybody's
terrified of cholesterol somebody here
was asking about eating eggs and people
don't want to eat eggs I don't want to
eat the yolk and eggs and there's so
much misunderstandings about cholesterol
please tell our listeners tell it tell
the viewers a little bit about first of
all what cholesterol is why it's so
important and then okay how you can take
and make sure that you have enough
cholesterol in your body using dietary
strategies well first of all cholesterol
is an important part of our human
structure every cell wall is like 30%
cluster right okay
every cell wall if the trillions and
trillions of cells your body every one
of them 30% or more in some cases 60%
the cell wall is muscle so you can't
make you can't make cells without the
stuff that's right and cells won't work
without it they die without it
and then 75% of your brain weight the
white matter of your brain the myelin
cholesterol is cholesterol okay if you
don't have enough cholesterol guess what
you get alzheimers disease it's a
physician cause disease for lowering
your cholesterol then you can't make sex
hormones testosterone estrogen
progesterone and adrenal hormones are
all steroid hormones ninety-five percent
by weight is clever girl vitamin d3 is
question seven hydroxy 25 cholesterol
right cortisol hormone exactly so how
the adrenal hormones all these things
are cholesterol so you don't have enough
cholesterol you get erectile dysfunction
you get menopause you get adrenal
exhaustion you get Alzheimer's disease
all of it all of it how can this thing
this beautiful chemical this beautiful
molecule B so demonized in our culture
it's amazing to me well here's why
because again biologists don't know
anything about chemistry right doctors
don't know anything about nutrition
right so that's a maximum well in 1971
after having done 20,000 autopsies I
wrote a paper which compared the plugged
arteries and vegans versus plugged
arteries and meat-eaters looking at this
cholesterol series right the vegans are
eating what the grains grains vegetables
fruits and nuts and guess who had the
worst clogged arteries be vegans right
because of the author on me well
there was a little bit of cholesterol in
the in the scarring of the arteries and
that's why they in their brains they
thought it was a cholesterol but there
was turbulence in there and the body's
putting cholesterol and they're trying
to smooth it out you know like these
non-stick pans now the body's response
was to throw cholesterol out of trying
to smooth out the turbulence now when
people eat meat is there cholesterol in
steak because they're actually course
omok even after it's cooked and a yes
process you know as long as you don't
burn it okay now but here's here's the
beauty of that study 1971 20,000 autopsy
they come out and this is published in
an international Danish pathology
general act two pathological translated
into six languages this went around
millions of doctors millions of
pathologists all over the world read
this now they all laughed at me because
they're saying well Wallach must be
sniffing glue because cholesterol causes
heart disease well guess what we're
we're vegans getting their cholesterol
they're not eating meat they're not
eating eggs they're making it the oils
in the grains are oxidizing because they
were stored improperly so now and then a
stir fry an extra extra extra virgin
virgin virgin olive oil you turn those
oils into trans fatty acids and
heterocyclic amines right by heating
them eat a lot of salad dressings
where's the cholesterol coming from the
from the body makes a little bit as a
sort of again a protective our detective
device kind of like this non-stick pan
again right okay but is it came from
your own body up regulating your the
body's manufacturing system of
cholesterol yeah but it's
infinitesimally small wasn't even a
factor but they pick that's the only
strange thing that was in there right
and so they picked that out for some
reason they came up with these statin
drugs to lower cholesterol well here
comes now 41 years later the FDA in
science news just a couple of weeks ago
came out and said Oh houston we have a
problem they put out new warnings on
stand drug saying IV you well if it
increases your risk of diabetes by 50%
increases your risk of Alzheimer's
disease by 100%